we're surrounded be cool oh there's me
go I've been working with Sam and Nico
since 2009 today I'm going to go to the
lifeline said my boy said Nico are
shooting the biggest project of their
careers I'm like a proud papa watching
them and seeing them in action and
hopefully you guys learn something along
the way come on yeah well I don't have a
car last week picked up this like that
wasn't working let me show you
I wonder why these life governor's
wonder what these lights are made like
brick they can take an atom bomb I'll
plug the light in give it power turn it
on presents or not but you look
carefully right here the fan is actually
spinning so the control panel or the
light actually works that's a problem
where's the set across the street
[Music]
for that
I don't know they're somewhere in here
we don't know where I say let's go this
way go back outside I think it's still
up further that's what the studio is
it's just on the margin or do you were
right naked showing round
part of the form of another Chloe's
right here
[Music]
no no twice of course I'll just check in
the summer and I haven't checked it in
several days I'm a mod so I can change
this I think this is not acceptable I
want to change that you didn't notice it
no I hadn't noticed it until you pointed
it out now it's all in a week that's the
one that likes the people 8 on fear
factor um we do I'm editing that scene
about that subreddit actually the photo
was removed since then yeah so I'm just
looking for a clip exact clip time
context is one already
yes I'm warm what is the freakin bite me
I'll need to shut up
[Music]
that Iraqi let's get lunch spider
comarca spire bail
[Music]
where we can work it on my mind yeah
where it's that where's it says upstairs
upstairs which love the book okay thank
you thank you closer
we'll find it something who is just a
stand down well how do we get to the
second floor
six stairs oh yeah get you the story
thank you you go detected me just broke
for lunch down the street at Grand
Central Market
let's go oh here we are
now we have to find Nico and Sam it's
like being at a CIA location is that
that guy where comes that you see people
with the little radios probably it's
like FBI holy house where Nico is oh
there's makeup I think you can't just go
up to him dude we're surrounded if we
just go up to him we're getting it
attack serious people we have trained
into
one slot for ginger
hey what's up guys hey welcome to the
lunch yeah this is a really nice light
that we like to use it doesn't work
jared has an idea of what could be wrong
with it let's ask it okay in production
lights have color their color
temperature tungsten which is kind of
orange II and daylight which is blue you
like accordingly so that if Y balance is
opposed
that's production lighting in a very
very basic bottom line
these are tungsten LEDs if once we tee
off
we also have daylight LEDs one when he
needs one 20 t power source 120 deep if
we instead hook this up to you the
proper guy that might fix this okay and
again my ticks call from the
telemarketer come going striking
[Music]
[Applause]
apparently you can you know hit
technology and make it weak well there
we go there you go
[Music]
sure so lesson learned when working with
the tungsten or the daylight aperture
120 light you want to make sure you
don't mix up the controller panel or
else it won't actually work good to know
huh
well we finally found this on the
lifeline and we're here to say we feel
hi guys
through the set of flight lines
headquarters we call it bullpen just
look at the rear Sam it's not rare
you guys are rare I'm always here this
is our main headquarters said I don't
know how much we sure they're going to
show us so it's the kind of stuff that
like sites pick up and then I'll be good
try just blur everything except my face
just look how cool we're shooting all
our headquarters beans in this sweet
sweet sweet studio here taking the whole
space apart throwing huge desk tons of
light installations stuff a full
background extras and stuff to make it
look like a buckling office it's crazy
we've been shooting for over five weeks
now if I didn't we're back in your that
is hey guys were back we're back in well
semanas welcome the other thing we're
going to take this opportunity to show
you guys a little bit about the
differences between a very large set the
way things work on those sets versus how
the way things work when were just
shooting youtube videos I was fortunate
enough to flooding New York City to meet
the rock he smells great did you call
him did you call him Billy I told him
when I called him Dwayne there was a
magical part of my life
sad to see it gone forever wait so you
mean that he made it to the top with
with hard work and dedication yeah hard
work and dedication
oh yeah performed